[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch Invincible episode three
of season 2 today Gregs and shorts
because Greg just came from the gym
that's right reject apparel is good for
any occasion sleeping casual Hangouts
parties family gatherings or going to
the gym it always works joined once
again by Aaron Alexander Aaron the
Alexander how are you Aaron Alexander at
Instagram
Alexander the realex that is me Aaron
Alexander Aaron Alexander Instagram and
and Tik Tok I Aaron Alexander I'm doing
well today on this this beautiful day
how are you Greg Alba it's the Greg Alba
totally promoted okay whatever how are
you the Greg Alba don't worry about it
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like on this video that would be
exceptional be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell because we
got episode 4 to go to as well for next
week of season 2 also thank you to
everyone who's joined us on our patreon
especially for invincible that really
means a lot that's where you get the
full inat watch along where you sync
with your own copy of invincible we also
cover several shows over there they're
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included all righty guys let's do
[Music]
it where you going time to push my baby
bird out of the nest it's good thing I
can already fly you going to be okay
right that's cute we going to college
already did you just graduate last
episode I promised myself I wouldn't cry
oh this past year has just been so oh
wow we've time jumped a whole year
but college is a fresh start feel like
it's a few months cuz he's just starting
College I really want a clear indicator
of the time span here or else I'm going
to think about it the entire episode
give me Clarity show I got your card
from my friend Olga my name is Debbie
yeah yeah yeah no uh sorry no last names
Debbie but Olga told me about you what
is this Seance dog really what are we 12
h does that look crooked to
you yeah very you already have a
girlfriend and you're superhero I on the
other hand am single and have no
superpowers and thus actually have to
attempt game well he can't use his
superpowers to get a girl I would 100%
Magnum P when it's on the door handle
like so it means go eat a taco or fly to
Spain or do whatever you have to do but
don't come in until the sock is gone
respect the sock there's some stuff out
here do it belone to you guys toys uh
they're
collectibles who's this dog this an
indie Universe superhero yeah seems like
it some Easter egg which is odd because
put in the comments
engage it looks up to that dog I'm sure
it exists in another Multiverse I think
that was a robot uh action figure what
are you doing that wouldn't surprise me
within this universe oh I think they
might be um it's like doctor strange but
a dog I don't know what I was thinking
is his name dogor
[Laughter]
strange who has sex on the first day of
college damn lots of people probably us
for example hey get it my roommate
doesn't arrive until tomorrow we have
the whole place to ourselves uh okay I
mean have they not done it before yeah
have you been saving
yourselves definitely
not I bought these oh she knew good good
to have those he would break
those he's
Invincible wait you don't have like
super or something do you oh they've
never done it before Oh [__] seems
normal wow not that I would I think it's
fine and you wouldn't accidentally crush
me or something these are very valid
questions we never see them addressed in
any comic book show or movie boys kind
of does oh fair you're right you're
right turn off the lights first no Dam
oh my God super powers
baby and turn our attention to the Stars
W and a story that began Generations ago
in this missive this
mination on the planet yopa a peaceful
and thriving world the yopin had
achieved harmony with nature and
Technology who who's narrating right now
I don't know everything changed in the
blink of an watching how the vites
destroyed them a dark force invaded yopa
this when ay man comes back the yopin
that died never knew who their
conquerors were the ones that lived
quickly learned the
name Vite yep okay we bringing it back
however the unopen spirit was UN broken
biting their time for decades they
waited for a moment of weakness and
rebelled that'll do no good they still
underestimated their
oppressors team vulture might let's
go
ooh they all look the
same they're not real people that's why
it's
easy some yopin were able to escape and
the promise of a new
life within a generation wa look at a
lot of legs breeding camps on various
unopen outposts to rebuild their
population ah neat fadus the leader of
the Coalition of planets invited them to
the planet telesa to join their ranks so
interesting weing this whole backstory
yeah right the Vite campaign has become
the scourge of the Galaxy and We Stand
United against it that's Optimus Prime
oh the breeding camps were also a
genetic enhancement program designed to
breed a soldier that could defeat a Vite
in combat are we building up to Allen
the results
were not promising until
Allan yep yep the super soldier Allan
Allan was trained to be the greatest
fighter the universe had ever
known and a opponent could not be found
who didn't fall to his might love this
reintroduction of him was cool they
literally built a hero to defend
themselves Allan still couldn't match
even a single Vite in combat the program
was considered a
failure man was made a planetary
evaluation officer sent to discover any
being able to defeat him may be true
that Allan was supposed to be keeping
tabs on the planet
Ura his mistake led him to Mark Grayson
happy accident love how this feels like
an 80s sci-fi movie I was just thinking
it was feeling like like a Serial you
have to
be
alien are we completely shifting
Focus this is experimental yeah I'm so
down for it yeah I to see where this
goes song always has great music the
show always has great music data log
hello to you too here you
go e what a weird face it's like
detached almost yes I found the right
Planet because it was the wrong planet
you already found before is it still a
mistake if it ends up saving the
universe no it's F yes okay I guess
agree or disagree this feels like Star
Trek we need more
then good thing I found us one oh Mark
Grayson you warn the Earth Champion that
a Vite lives among his
people I love that it's Optimus Prime
it's just this dude his name is Mark and
he's only half
Vite that battle Beast no it's not
probably the same race though when he
got his powers all he wanted to do was
help other humans then his father
decided it was time to conquer the
planet so they they got in a fight about
it that has not happened since the Great
Purge since the rise of the ALS
spark he just wants to protect his world
and Conquer others in its name no you're
being
racist give him a chance even Across the
Universe they feel it's inevitable for
years we've been searching for a hole in
the vit's armor Allan is Right vites
never abandon their missions yet one
has I can't get over it but a son defies
his father these are weaknesses love how
it looks like a classic depiction of God
you have done well Alan and given us
much to discuss we will call on you
again
soon he's playing Optimus par there is
hope for Cybertron after
all they have no idea what this means if
there are other Vite kids out there
maybe we can turn them against their
parents too no that just start with Mark
and leave it at that for a
while we got one down we're okay you
want me to discover if someone's
betrayed us
that's him most valuable
asset thank you sir if there's a mole
I'll find them he's the mole you think
he's the mole why would he make him what
a great way to throw someone to hide in
plain sight but to even to make him
aware of the fact that there's a mole
why would he do that to himself Aaron I
refuse to believe I'm
wrong even when you bring up a very
logical
points I know you weren't suspicious of
anything but let me give you something
to be suspicious about and I'll I'm the
person you should be suspicious of what
a weird you did yes you did you did miss
your daddy didn't you I love how much
more layers were getting to Allen he's
actually coming across like badass did
you miss me oh I missed you yeah how
much the most or like yep I knew what
this was let's see if that's
true oh yeah oh
yeah oh goodness
tentacles time to return to Earth and
rejoin Amber Bennett and Mark Grayson no
we just started getting going let's get
freaky with some
tentacles oh I see uh
[Laughter]
no who to cut to well
um Al Eve the unopen feline he has one
large eye in the center of his
head that doesn't stop him from having
all manner of household
Adventures that's like some avatar
creature that air bender just like some
hybrid how do you eat canlock it's
disgusting he doesn't think so it's so
sad they're squirming they're
scared oh
no this is horrible the food is eating
food that's hilarious The Circle of Life
hey what did Theus want to talk about
after the council meeting look I'm not
really supposed to
uh is she the mole I believe she's the
mole now that would be that would be
narratively conflicting I'm supposed to
satisfying
[Music]
oh what oh what oh no we're meeting them
oh
god oh come on Alan I don't know how
you're going to survive this but answer
our questions and we will consider
sparing your life you will tell us
everything about your encounter with the
VTR light of earth oh they're after omn
man oh my God are you certain he
abandoned his post oh [__] do they
punish him and really like to
know God they're so powerful just slap
like it's nothing this is not good man
this is not good which one was he again
you B clops all kind of look the same to
me B
clops no damn oh my
God this is awful
[Music]
no dude [__] yo what kind of
interrogation is
this my God oh my God no his ey oh my
God oh my God what are they doing kill
[Music]
them what the hell is going on no tell
me this isn't this isn't our Earth maybe
this is a Multiverse thing maybe this
isn't the R
Allen oh this is so sad dude someone has
to repair him they wouldn't they
wouldn't give us that whole thing about
the the mole and and just kill him
immediately was so
heartbreaking oh he's alive we don't
know if this is him I'm going guess that
is yeah it is him we don't know it could
be a different
one I refuse to believe I'm
wrong I still [__] shot I was like
didn't just do that how how did he
survive that that's insane the mole gave
information to V mites okay okay that
that makes sense they once again
underestimate the inopen will to
survive there the mole to come here
attack alen at home the vites must know
we've discovered something that scares
them you should get some rest I will
watch over him he's the
mole I was going to kill him I was going
to kill him you're right you're [__]
right you why would he tell him there
was a mole in the first place what made
you think he was the mole forgive me
Alan got to leave something for the
review while Greg thinks of an answer
what already no way no no that's no this
is a mislead has to be yeah we haven't
been back yet yep this ends the Allen
part of the episode the structure on
this is so odd and I love it I'm so here
for it this is so strange the best
episode of the season so far oh oh wow
you cheated on me with the immortal
that's what you think happened even if
that was true you were cheating on Eve
with me first how does it make it okay
that worked out in your
favor The Immortals like 2,000 years old
you know that's what makes him
experienced we are probably the same age
I'm too young for you now I is that it
you're just an [__] well how is that
news Fair Point The Immortals the only
person I've ever met who's died as many
times as I have oh [__] but it means
something they feel every death gets it
I never thought of it like that damn
hello Chums I'd like to run while
remaining in a stationary location is
that cool
beans where are you from for Real where
are you from go ahead shapes Smith I'll
just be over there in a stationary
location he does not understand the
concept of a
treadmill I set up this visual feedback
system so I could practice controlling
my fear response via meditation and
active thought are you sure that's a
good idea people feel fear for a reason
and it's usually a good reason helps you
Keen sense of awareness I guess you'll
find out the hard way have fun next time
you fall off a cliff or
[Music]
something can you just remove that part
from your brain fear hasn't just made me
use in battle it's prevented me from
doing something else I've wanted to do
for quite some time oh tell her you love
her oh will you go to a movie with me
oh sure sure Rudy uh uh why uh that's
cute you became this for her I know just
the way she responded to it she's like
yeah sure why not oh my God you better
give him [__] in the comments for that
guys I'm protecting your ass on that
weaponizing an army
now we're not that different from other
support groups excepts to Identity first
names only you aren't required to share
till you're ready but that's why we're
all sacrificing a Tuesday nights you're
required to but you know don't waste our
time yeah I wonder if people would even
hear her out if they found out her
husband was homy man you know probably
not well they proba they'd have empathy
for her you know once they got to know
her then she revealed it I feel like it
be divisive Mark respond back to your
mom I didn't say much at my first
meeting either I can leave you alone no
it's fine I I dropped my son off at
college today empty house yeah it's okay
I totally get it we all
do there's a bar down the street some of
us like to go to after group I just
figured since it seems like neither of
us wants to go home but no pressure of
course I don't miss
you someday you'll have to tell me all
about your childhood oh we're already
seeing a horror movie tonight do you
know if he and Rex are the same voice
actor cuz they're clones you just use
different same actor okay two tickets
for midnight Slaughter That's rated R I
see and you need your parents to buy you
RR tickets come back come back as an
adult how does a parent presence change
a film suitability for the
underage it's fine they're my kids they
can see the movie how you do that this
might be your first movie but it's not
mine you'd be surprised what people will
do for 10 bucks if this is your first
movie What other normal stuff haven't
you done ice cream oh okay Burger
yeah I love this Slice of Life stuff I'm
so endeared by this a good burger and
fries is one of the greatest Pleasures
in life yes I'm discovering
that oh my God robot's going to get
fat
did you move after your partner passed
away I moved the furniture couldn't
afford to relocate do we know who the
partner is I don't think we do yet I
think it's um the green girl fzy girl
part of the Guardians yeah that would
make things complicated her husband
killed his wife yeah it's good to talk
with someone who understands I wish I
could tell you it gets easier but
Alana's been gone nearly a year and I
still reach across the bed for her every
morning Alana m I mean yeah C it she was
the green ghost C it yikes she got
murdered by that alien
psychopath I didn't know she had a
partner oh he's drinking she wanted to
protect
[Music]
me woof I'm kind of still screwed up
about what happened to Rick I always
imagine we be here at Upstate together
hard CES said he's doing better man and
the grief of this season for
real some
capacity hey I bet that's somebody ready
for round two coming ambers omn man
evance just cast a paw over this whole
thing Mark
Grayson is that the narrator I think
so Mark
Grayson that's awesome who are you why
it is I Seance dog Seance dog Seance dog
isn't real he's a comic book character
Multiverse in your dimension yes but
there exists Myriad other world where
dogs and Magic are as real as the air
you
breathe this voice is great open your
mind and let me help you reach the other
side hey well whatever you're doing
don't Oh no you're going to how's no one
looking mask
bro you don't understand
man what are you doing Mark talk to him
who are you and what do you
want you lied my name is nalot I am from
the planet thraxa my people sent me to
plead for your help okay rumors of the
one they call Invincible have spread
like wildfire your speed your strength
you're the only one who can save our
people from the meteor shower is
destroying our world do it Mark how many
bug people are in danger 42 billion damn
don't worry about your classes I'll
cover for you somehow why do you care so
much because last time you didn't want
to help someone we both regretted it but
college is everything you can't just go
to some random planet with some random
alien are you insane shut up
Cecil a lot of people died because of me
Cecil this is a chance to save lives
billions of them you do anything to help
because of his guilt I need to listen to
myself before I listen to you you your
father felt the same way that's
manipulative you're missing the Nuance
Cil how's it going hey come to your
window and before last season he would
have to kind of make up some [__]
Happ be there's transparency now I have
to go away for a few weeks to space
again A lot of people are going to die
if I don't I'm sorry but I stop stop
never apologize for saving lives
self
go be
careful always they not said I love you
Amber I um yeah I love
you that [__] hung oh no no no okay I
just keep assuming the worst about
women it takes time to heal I can't heal
because my husband's not dead he's gone
because because he murdered Alana and
the other
Guardians why would you tell her that
your husband's omn man I wish I could
grieve and move on but I can't I I can't
I wish he was dead too oh my God no you
shouldn't come back to the group yep
wouldn't be a safe space with you
[Music]
there that hurts Invincible huh we're
here W time freaky colorful really
purple the Grimace Design This Wait what
exactly about this planet needs saving
we're the meteors what made
what the ones that are killing billions
oh yeah those meteors don't worry the
Monarch will explain all oh [__] don't
trust him he started this interaction
with deception and then you followed him
to space anyway may I present Invincible
of Earth is it omn man I don't know who
are we expecting is it a different
vulture M hello
son it's been a while
[Music]
oh
Dad this
crazy the hell's he doing there right
what the
hell oh wow damn what a reveal what a
crazy
reveal that was such a long post credit
scene is there no more they normally do
like the the immediate after I guess
they kind did it earlier [__] he see
episode one of season 1 did this similar
thing Rob Delaney episode one of season
1 did a similar thing but it was only
like 10 and 15 minutes this was like the
end of the Allen chapter and then they
just went into it yeah it's weird it
kind of like snaps your brain into like
focusing more right CU make you think
it's over it's like there's something
important yeah wow yeah oh man that was
so
good God but you know what else is
really
good if you go to
www.re naations
shop.com and they travel through space
here so much they're like the space
babies of the Galaxy you know what I
mean or you know like this he has to
protect people like our child protection
services with Pedro and grou there
together and we also got like who
influences the influencers com book
inspired we got a whole bunch of other
te's as well that we absolutely love
like America's ass and you know we just
a whole bunch of things but it is one of
the best ways my favorite way to support
the channel thank you to all bought tees
if you buy a tea tag us on social media
I want to I'll make sure to like add you
to the stories and stuff thank you guys
so much Aon Aon Greg we got 13 minutes
to talk oh man so many things so many
things have happened in this wonderful
45ish to 49 minute episode the speed of
your talking is amazing right now speed
up like koi you want to talk like five
we can be quality efficient here okay
episode really good loved the beginning
with Allen uh got to explore more of him
I thought Seth Rogan did a fantastic job
he kind of disappeared into this
character shout out Optimus Prime he was
really cool too you called being the
mole I don't know how you did that that
was that was crazy I was like why would
he reveal himself to be the mole making
him suspicious and then be the mole I
don't know I don't know shit's weird uh
but that fight was really brutal in the
beginning and yeah I think all the
things that are that were set up from
the end of last season are now coming to
fruition which makes me a
little not not confused but like curious
as to like how's the stuff with the
Multiverse going to tie into this stuff
because we didn't even really touch it
or address it in this episode also where
was Eve this entire episode we didn't
really talk about that but I think the
stuff that I did really like was us
getting to explore some of the
characters that we really got attached
to and got to know in the first first
season got to spend more time with Rex
and duplicate and robot and monster girl
and I was really invested in those
things in the first season so I'm happy
that we're finally getting those
characters some light in this season and
yeah some really interesting cool
reveals you know with with omn man at
the end there I was like was not
expecting that and I I feel really bad
for Debbie I feel really bad for Debbie
because she opened up was vulnerable
clearly distraught about all the things
that have happened and he's he was just
like nah get out of here you're trash
just like don't come around here like
you you don't to see this woman as
geving too like clearly affects her as
well so yeah I everyone's going through
it you know whether it
be om not omn man whether it be
duplicate going through the grieving
process and connecting with Immortal but
the fact that they've died multiple
times and kind of like the grief and
like trauma that comes with that or
you know just the stuff with Debbie and
we didn't really get too much into
Mark's grief this episode but clearly
his guilt uh from all of the Fallout of
what happened last season permeates
throughout all of this season so far and
yeah I enjoyed it I really did what
about you man what you
think yeah was good man good good stuff
everything's good everything's good
everything's good everything's great
yeah I think that the
the episode was structured in a way that
was so different than any other episode
of invincible and I really appreciate
when they deviated from it because it it
leads to an element of everything
feeling unexpected you know like to go
from this time Jump where Mark is in
college which again is like a that's
such a superhero kind of plotline of
someone trying to balance it out very
Peter Parker es and you're like I don't
I don't know what the point of view even
[__] doing this really is honestly
man like what you
why why everyone know a college on a
broke anyway right yall have student
loan debts right shout out student loan
debt shout out student loan debts shout
out the few who become really successful
after
college no go to school get educated
stay educated um go to education for go
for the education but anyway um yeah go
that plot line and then as you talked
about with the grief that sort of cast a
PA over this entire episode but what was
really cool about this was how they
really expanded the universe like it
seems like this section of invincible
the first season was very much like
focused in this one they're opening up
it's still focused but in a different
kind of way where they're opening up the
doors for what is really possible within
this universe like we got multiverses we
got these different planets you got
different space exploration I thought it
was really cool how you can take an
episode where you take a certain chunk
out of it focus on this completely other
realm with thus with Allen and
I find myself like so invested in that
that I didn't even want to cut away from
it I wanted to just stay
there deal with the plot of like
whatever conspiracies happening and then
they even open up the door of course
with the vulture mites as well where
they're like interrogating Allen they're
whooping his ass and pretty much like
nearly kill the guy and they're also on
the hunt for omn man and they're it
seems like they they need to make a
decision on whether or not they punish
or execute omn Man based off of him not
fulfilling his mission and then to tie
it in to the very end of this where it
looks like omn man has decided to be
like a he's a fugitive he's escaped like
this is just a theory haven't read the
comics so that's what makes a lot of
this really fun as we have no idea what
direction it's going but then when you
go to omn man at the very end the
impression that it gives you is like did
he reform in some way because he
couldn't follow through with do uh the
Domin do dominating Earth that now he
has become some benevolent ruler because
everything seems so peaceful everything
and he is the ruler of that planet but
there's a sense of ethereal jovial kind
of resonating throughout that entire
planet wait a minute this is not the omn
manulera of cool about seeing the
multiverses at the beginning as you and
seeing how vites dominate like Allen's
Planet you see what kind of rulers the
vites are I'm like this is not the way a
Vite rules right you know so like how
how much has he changed is it is it an
act is there some bigger planet like
what what door is it opening up and he
still wants to connect with his son you
know and like they also seem really
threat in the vites by him having a son
you know did he really have a SE they
said something about like having another
seed or something like that you know
yeah something to that effect yeah it's
I want to watch my words here because
really we' getting a lot of
demonetization on stuff like H with a
lot randomly in the past week so I'm
trying to watch my language here
especially uh but a lot of this seemed
to deal with sexuality this episode you
know what I mean like between Paul and
uh between Mark and uh amber even Allen
and then also like the idea of you know
omn man having a kid and like the seed
carrying on like there there's a sort of
element there that I did and then even
like going to college and stuff like the
whole thing with William which I thought
was also a really great thing to bring
back around is like they're not dropping
the ball on anything here they're not
dropping um any plot line just to like
they're not sacrificing character
development for jokes or Whimsy or to
keep the fun
going apparently a lot of audiences are
okay with for certain
properties but for this they're for this
one they they bring it back in a way
that where that Nuance just is so felt
like with like with William bring I'm
like thank thank God they did that like
you know that was such an important that
was an impactful episode last season and
they they brought it back around and it
shows that William just not like all
right I'm over it I'm going to have fun
with every guy hang you know I can bang
or something like that you know and
still affecting him it's everything's
still affecting them and and then um
whatever Corner they're painting Debbie
into is just completely Bleak and
harrowing on all fronts you know that it
it seems so real too that they would
blame the I mean this guy has a very
biased subjective take because his wife
was directly murdered by omn man and he
need and they don't have omn man to
blame because omn man's not around right
so you know and it's it's we've seen it
happen with people who marry like a
serial killer and they don't know it you
should have known and they get blamed
you know and so I like that realistic
element of Debbie just just trying to
find grief she's trying to grief she's
trying to move on that sense of loss of
like it' be easier to grieve if he was
dead but there's also this fear of
unknown that he might actually come back
so how can I really get over it and on
top of that when I try to open up I'm
just going to get blamed and shunned
because I married that guy you know and
it makes you fear for debie who's just
trying to keep it
together yeah I think it's as you were
talking I was I was kind of listening to
some of the the points you're bringing
up about like just kind of listening to
some of it yeah yeah you know just some
of it kind of like Zone and
[__] but no no I definitely agree I
agree with your your sentiment about
about and like the path that she's going
down and yeah the the fact that she
didn't really see any of this coming and
she didn't ask for any of this but I
think the the thing that kind of
percolated my my brain the the most as
you're talking is like the the
still Loring effects of omn man I know
that we're kind of talking about like
damn this Show's like really missing omn
man like where's omn man at and I think
they chose a perfect time to reintroduce
that character into the show because we
have now been in this state of like
people being paranoid both on Earth and
intergalactically of Mark and his
intentions and we've seen from the
beginning of the Season that in other
universes him and his dad team up so now
we're seeing an omn man that can't go
back to Earth who also can't go back to
vmite so he's just like this dude who
still loves his son and now he's two
galaxies away and they're going to
reconnect so like what does that
reconnection look like are they going to
rekindle their relationship obviously
Mark is going to have some strong
feelings about that is omn man going to
be able to be reformed is that something
that's in the cards is that something
that interests him is that something
that the show even can not sustain but
like I don't know what what would that
look like and does that cause further
mistrust if he does form a relationship
with his dad and if he's forming a
relationship with his dad at this point
in the show how is that going to affect
the things that's going on with this new
multiversal villain and is he going
is that guy get like the wrong idea
about the fact that omn and Mark are now
reunited again because those two as a
force is [__] deadly to uh the the
survival or the the health of Earth or
maybe it's a manipulation Ploy with that
omn man is playing some type of bigger
game here or if it's not even omn man
what if it's just another shape shifting
but that would be that wouldn't be
satisfying we got the shape shifting
element there we have and then oh and
also the sexuality too the the
um re flod and duplicate and all that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think they
just bring a lot of depth to everyone's
getting like an extra pound of death
depth here which I think is so cool like
I I love seeing Rudy and uh monster girl
whatever her name
is I know it's not monster girl I love
seeing them hang out with each other and
just those like poignant Slice of Life
things where he is really learning about
Humanity in a way like he's he's
understanding human emotion like he
keeps trying to control it in the most
analytical sense and finding weaknesses
and things from having been so detached
for so long and he finds himself pulled
to certain feelings of love and then
other little things that bring the most
Joy like the taste of a good burger you
know yeah uh I think there's so many
great I I love this episode a lot I
thought it was a really really great
episode I was very much hooked from
beginning to end and watching the
development like Amber Mark as well um
everything about it that was excellent
yeah I wonder what the trajectory of
Amber and Mark's relationship is and
like are they going to stay together for
the entirety of the show how is that
going
to affect them because like we've been
in granted they're having this open
communication dialogue now but how long
can that form of their relationship be
sustainable true cuz she's not a super
hero he always has to go off you know
he'll outli her he'll outli her yeah
he's he's he's a Vite you know he's
going to age a lot slower than her so
these I think these are things that are
going to come to head
eventually yeah so I'm curious to see
where those things go but yeah it was a
great episode overall loved it guys what
would you rank that episode um I give it
like a 10 out of 10 for me I really love
the hell out of that episode guys I
would say the same yeah that was
excellent best epis of the season so far
absolutely
undeniably and Man shows up at the
Answer Man shows up I might get some
views on
this he's going in the thumbnail yeah
right away instantaneously thumb yeah
not even we're not even
in title video omn man's back inin
episode
three we're just really small in the
corners guys leave your thoughts down
below thank you so much for being here
be sure to subscribe and click that
notification Bell and H S with
a
what's going on guys so there's only a
few I keep messing that up every time I
say it there's only so many days left in
the month there is one day left in the
month so we have to shout out at least
two patrons for Patron the day sh to
make sure we are getting our obligations
taken care of G and uh today I am going
to choose to throw in Michael B and
Danny pank
hey so Michael be let's start with you
omn media Michael band cakes really
helpful behind the scenes with the
channel has obviously collabed here done
several videos with him he's did just
one with John recently for Mission
Impossible right often help each other
out with advice sometimes super late at
night uh it just overall has been this
incredible Gem and has been one of our
like OG patrons for the longest time and
refuses to unpledge even though I've
said please stop your making making
things awkward this is a conflict of
interest uh but he continues to do so
and I think the with the goal in mine is
that whatever we pay him when he does a
collab with us that he's just getting
all that money back eventually but I
don't think he has I don't even think
he's close to breaking even that's why
he's on YouTube is someday breaking yeah
so I appreciate uh everything you do man
you've been a absolutely amazing
indominable spirit in our lives and
Danny pancakes I Don't Know Jack sh
about you uh I just wanted to say um
thanks for pancakes because they're
delicious I I don't get to meet eat them
that often and I I you know I have them
with butter and syrup like every other
human being you unless you're one of
those freaks who's like I want a syrup
on my pancakes like dry P some people
like a dry pancake and I think that's
kind of gross I don't know what kind of
pancake eater you are Danny pancakes
it's not Danny pancakes and syrup I'll
tell you that yeah that's true man
there's no syrup in that last name so
could just be the D sford dry pancake on
Danny and then you know Danny I have an
uncle Danny and uh he's never done
anything illegal to me so I like my
uncle Danny and he likes pancakes and he
likes pancakes very much so with
strawberry syrup actually and and you
know like Danny Rand is easily the most
underrated character in all Netflix MCU
H so you know like pink things saying
you know like Dany and pancakes those
are just a great combination to me so I
just want to say thank you for somehow I
had more to say about during your
segment than I did someone who I really
know and talk to on the phone but I
there are just so many great Danny's so
great pancakes you know I mean like if
Danny ocean was ever seen in a breakfast
time scene Rusty would be eating
pancakes there's so many correlations
like yeah I could thank you for just
pledging and for being here for as long
long as you have been that's boring you
get that from any patreon page we just
got to really focus on like why you
chose the name Danny pancakes you know
there's another Danny I know is Daniel
last name Melgar since he was a baby now
he's like one of the smartest people
I've ever known yeah he's Jack of many
tra Danny how much how much has Danny
pledged to us over time oh uh uh a a fat
stack of flap Jacks I'll tell you that
190 that's amazing man dude amazing
let's see if we can get this to 2000
that's a lot 2000 I believe in stepping
stone goals so we go from $190 to
$2,000 let's get you up to two grand all
right just stick around stick around you
got a ways to go $2,000 man you're
dedicated believe in it appreciate you
oh [__] know you've been with us for a
long time cting fat stats May Since 2021
yeah God damn D you been here a long ass
time Hell's yeah
since yeah dude how many months is that
that's a I'm trying to make another
pancake joke and I don't have one for
this bit but April no man we'll figure
it out hold on hold on a
second okay hold on hold on a sec if
someone has been a has has
given me
$190 in
total starting from April 2020
to nov
2023 how much is that per
month that this information is this is
great we can see the you know at what
hold on a second let's unusual activity
what what like no one asked this
question yeah what's going on this is
not that they're like what a strange
question to ask me I'm not asking you to
like speculate on like the world's bank
or something like that stupid AI tell me
what I want to know yeah okay I so he's
average
$6.3 per month okay so what is 2,000
divided by
613 okay so all right or how many more
months would it take to get to how many
more months will it take to get he gets
to
$2,000 um so don't worry Danny I'm going
to get you an answer I know I know
you're you're really trying to like set
some goals here yeah yeah yeah but and
and I mean not that to suggest that you
should stop after 2000 I'm just saying
we want to what the hell is wring really
doing with some hold on this is some
real complex math we could have figured
this out in the time that this is taking
it's really annoying math um it would
take about 296 more months okay that's
at least a couple years so if there's 52
months in a year wait no
is I mean there 12 months 52 months 12
months in the longest Year my life so 12
let's go two it's 24
56 uh I guess that would be uh that
would be like uh 20 something years
right something like that yeah they be
there in like 20 something years and
then 27 yeah what's what's 296 divided
by 12 no I can figure it out no it's
said 29 by 12 that's not how the math
goes right it's 296 divid by
$6 oh sure cuz it's how many months yeah
26 divid by six oh I'm trying to figure
out the years yeah oh oh my bad uh so we
need to figure out the years okay let me
do no I'm going to figure this out John
Jesus Christ you had six and a half
minutes last time going to get us to
eight all right so uh all right Danny
pancakes don't worry I got your cover
all right so okay 12 and that 24 56
what's 12 divid what's 56 divided by uh
12 uh uh oh God uh is that right math
yeah yeah yeah what's 565 by 12 it's a
12 * 4 is 48 12 * so yeah so it be like
24 and a half months okay all right pull
the calculator
correct four and a half years I mean
this 296 uh uh 296 divided by 12 24 24
and A2 months
baby66 almost 24 and a half yeah dude
all right well let's hope the patreon
let's hope patreon's still around by
then couple years from now patreon.com
is still around it's the biggest website
on Earth it can't go away all right
Danny you know what you got to do and uh
Michael um I'll send you a text
message we'll talk off camera and Shout
you out in a person
[Music]
life